في تفاصيل قضيه الفساد في النادي الكتلوني
اتهم القضاء الاسباني نادي برشلونه
ورئيسيه السابقين
وجوسيد بارتوميو والمسؤول التحكيم السابق
حسين جريره بالفساد واساءه الامانه وتزوير
سجلات تجاريه القطع الاسباني وجه
الاتهامات ايضا الى اوسكار جراو والبرت
سولار اللذين كان يعملان في اداره
بارتوميو حيث تتمحور التهم حول دفع اكثر
من سبعه ملايين دولار لنيجريره بين عامي
1994 و 2018 اداره برشلونه الحاليه بقياده
جوان لابورتا اكدت قبل ايام ان النادي
الكتلوني لم يشتري حكاما يوما ولم يكن له
نيه في فعل مثل هذه الاشياء محملا رئيس
رابطه الدوري الاسباني مساله الحمله
المزعومه ضد برشلونه انديه الدوري
الاسباني وصفت القضيه بالخطيره جدا مؤكده
ضروره كشف ما شابه من مخالفات فيما اعد
ريال مدريد نفسه ناد متضرر من قضيه نادي
برشلونه ونائب رئيس الحكام السابق قوسيه
[موسيقى]